hours ago congressman Seth Moulton
Massachusetts dropped out of the race
for the Democratic nomination confused
never heard of Seth Moulton you say
don't worry not many people have Moulton
served honorably in the United States
Marine Corps in Iraq four times other
than that he hasn't done a lot apart
from collecting useless college degrees
and running for office what's
interesting though is why he's being
forced to drop out of the race today by
any sane standard
Moulton is a thoroughly liberal Democrat
on every issue he's more left-wing than
Barack Obama was on the day he left
office three years ago he'd be
considered a liberal firebrand not
anymore by the lunatik standards of the
modern Democratic Party Seth Moulton is
now a flaming moderate and that's the
kiss of death moderates are not welcome
in the Democratic Party any longer watch
what happened for example the last
debate when congressman Tim Ryan of Ohio
urged his fellow liberals to take
practical considerations into account
they treated him like a man with an
infectious disease watch this now in
this discussion already tonight we've
talked about taking private health
insurance away from union members in the
industrial Midwest we've talked about
decriminalizing the border and we've
talked about giving free health care to
undocumented workers when so many
Americans are struggling to pay for
their health care I quite frankly don't
think that that is an agenda that we can
move forward on and win we've got to
talk about the working-class issues the
people that take the shower after work
who haven't had a raise in their 30
years if we focus on that we'll win the
election Thank You congressman
congressman no work your response sir
not a lot of applause for that
then when former Congressman John
Delaney gently tried to encourage his
party to restrict its ambitions to the
physically possible Elizabeth Warren
ordered him to be banished from
Wonderland forever
so I think wid when we run on real
solutions not impossible promises when
we run on things that are workable not
fairy tale economics you know I don't
understand why anybody does to all the
trouble of running for president of the
United States just to talk about what we
really can't do and shouldn't fight for
you and your reality based ideas how
dare you be gone
it's demented obviously but as a
political matter it's been highly
effective when he dropped out today
congressman Moulton noted that quote
it's evident this is now a 3-way race
between Biden won and Sanders and really
it's a debate about how far left the
parties should go except there isn't
really a debate the farthest left
candidates are winning of the nearly 20
people in the field only Biden Warren
and Sanders can muster more than 10
percent support which in fact makes it a
two-person race if we're gonna be honest
about it and why wouldn't we be Biden
may be a decent person but he's fading
he says weird things a lot he did it
again today in New Hampshire listen to
this my senior semester they're both
shot and killed imagine what would
happened if God forbid Barack Obama had
been assassinated after becoming the de
facto nominee what would have happened
in America imagine that your Biden's
political director sitting offstage and
all of a sudden he wanders into
unscripted territory and says imagine
the assassination of Barack Obama you've
got your head in your hands you're
frantically texting reporters trying to
get him to de-emphasize it let's be
honest this is not an attack on Joe
Biden he's not gonna be the nominee he's
not gonna be the president I mean
seriously
he's not so the actual race comes down
to Warren and Sanders competing visions
of how to achieve the same socialist
fantasy Warren is promising reparations
based on skin color that's popular
Sanders he wants a government take over
the entire energy sector uh-huh they'll
be working to out-crazy each other for
the next six months that is a dynamic
guaranteed to produce yet more extremism
and it has some Democratic leaders
worried yesterday for example the DNC
voted down a proposal to hold the debate
focused exclusively on climate change
why would they do that
well because the solutions the
candidates would promise live on
television are insane spend 16 trillion
dollars banned airplanes seize control
of the entire US economy uh-huh the
trustafarians love stuff like that
normal people find it terrifying even
the party hacks here in DC don't like it
and that's probably a compliment
honestly you really think Nancy Pelosi
believes climate changes an existential
crisis of course she doesn't think that
s why she flies private Barack Obama can
say whatever he wants about carbon
emissions and Stroke his chin and be
very very concerned but when you're
spending 15 million of your own dollars
on a beachfront estate in Martha's
Vineyard you're not really too worried
about the oceans rising the problem is
the Democratic base doesn't get the joke
Democratic primary voters believe the
talking points and very soon they'll be
powerful enough to nominate their own
presidential candidate when that happens
it's gonna be a very different party